in your opinion what is the biggest
internal economic threat in america
and what is the biggest external
economic threat to america
so these are pretty easy uh income
inequality
i think is the biggest risk to the u.s
economy it's
a lot of uh the driver behind
all of the divisiveness that we've seen
the protests
um the fires in the streets the the the
the political rancor
the rhetoric being as as hateful as it
is
this a lot of it comes down to the fact
that the haves have more than they ever
have
and they have nots have less than they
ever had so this massive divide
is very bad for the u.s economy is this
what we always hear about the k-shaped
economy the k-shaped economy exactly
exactly and that's how it's been uh and
it's still
going in that direction did that start
when did that really start because in
2008 during the recession you had the
well but you had you had the fed come
out and start printing money i mean it
really got going after 2008
because the fed's quantitative easing
policies
the printing of the money if you will
that tends to flow
into people into into portfolios
investment portfolios it helps out
people who have
stock holdings which is 55 percent of
americans right so
the other 45 percent are they have not
if you will because the fed's policies
don't reach them
and that's why you see discussions about
janet yellen and how she might get money
directly to the people but again
it's a slippery slope it's you know it's
it's socialism and drag
so how do we solve this income if that's
the biggest internal threat in america
how do we solve i know this is a bloated
question
yeah how do you solve income inequality
you you invest in productivity
you uh you do massive infrastructure
spending
that creates jobs you do what germany
does you have jobs re-skilling
i mean if if we're going to spend
taxpayers money why don't we give the
people who've been out of work
or whose industries have become you know
permanently
redundant like bricks and mortar
retailers i mean you've got
disney here in florida that's doing an
amazing business in their theme parks
at the same time they're closing 60 of
their re of the retail stores
throughout north america that's 60
people whose
jobs whose job skills aren't going to be
transferable because we're not
we're not turning back online shopping
we're going to continue to shop online
so but take that worker who's been
displaced and give them a new skill set
invest in productivity invest in
productivity invest in jobs reskilling
invest in
in in programs that create jobs and you
will
naturally grow the economy great
response now what do you think is the
biggest
external economic threat china one word
answer
china now just elaborate on that because
you know we talked about this earlier on
the podcast
we've been talking about china and all
the wrongdoings that they're doing and
and all their agenda made indeed 2025
what's the deal with china
it's bigger than that you know huawei
has a third
of the world's telecommunications
equipment a third
wow once that number gets to 50
the united states has basically lost the
war not the battle but the war
and where's the united states in that
number they have a third what
i mean oh my gosh yes and that's
that's the issue is that we've stopped
producing in america
what's going to carry the world into the
next generation whether it's artificial
intelligence
quantum computing telecommunications
equipment
semiconductor manufacturing this is all
next-gen
i mean your car your average car i think
it takes 200
semiconductors to build your average car
and we don't produce semiconductors
enough of them here
in the united states and so once china
wins this technological race pre-covet
the estimates were that china would
overtake the us economy in 2030.
pre-covert postcovid because they
obviously were able to force the their
will
upon the people to not move to shut down
so they were much more rigorous because
it's a communist nation they can be
controlling of their people
but china was able to reopen more
quickly
than a lot of places in the rest of the
world that kind of had in the middle
type of
coveted policies is the china thing
taking over the number one spot in the
economy
is it inevitable or is there a way it's
not just inevitable it is
it is happening so pre-cova 2030 was
when china was going to become the
largest right now the estimates are now
for 2028. if china's currency continues
to appreciate in value versus the dollar
it could be as soon as 2026 five years
for some reason have you ever seen the
movie uh ricky bobby
oh yeah okay great movie talladega
nights right
nights and like the most famous line in
that movie was he says
if you ain't first you're last true
right so america's been first for
70 plus years british pound sterling
started to decline
in 1921 it was shortly after after
world war one and that is when the
dollar began its
century-long rise so these things do go
in long cycles but we have to
understand that there are more than
economic implications to losing
the superpower status there there are
other geopolitical factors that we have
to take into account if china becomes
the largest economy and it appears to be
inevitable because again
look at look at post covid more than
five trillion dollars once we get this
next one 1.9 trillion more than five
trillion dollars
not a penny of it put into productive
means by our government
meanwhile back at the ranch china's got
30 airports that are under construction
and they've got high-speed railways and
our infrastructure's falling apart and
they're building out the next gen
so we just we've unfortunately president
trump's
trade policies put the focus on soybeans
which i mean china needs to import food
it's important
but their focus has been on
semiconductors
so soybeans semiconductors that's sort
of the
battle today tomorrow wow wow
so i'm going to have a drink to that
response i'll tell you that much that's
that was rough
i'm not going to have a drink to that
response because i hope that
i hope there's a third party initiative
i hope there's some kind of movement i
i'll totally get behind
to make government work again because
we're a big country we're a great
country we're
innovative people and we need to figure
out how to make government work for
everybody again
so i'll drink to that too because that's
that we can drink too that we can drink
america first america first
thank you for watching this short clip
if you want to see the full episode
check it out right here and if you have
not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here
[Music]
all we talk is money